Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie. This will be my full
Loki Season 2 Episode 2 Video
There were a whole bunch of Easter Eggs
and references,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes We're doing that
giveaway for the Loki Blu rays.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and just post your favorite moment
from the episode on the video.
And careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen it yet,
we'll start at the beginning
and work our way through Shot by shot.
Talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments,
starting with the episode titled
Breaking Bread, which is a reference to
Breaking Bad in the Brad Wolfe character
who is Hunter Zvi, played by Rafael Casal,
who does break Bad Going Rogue and
the TVA, and his mission to find Sylvie.
even though it was part of a big ruse,
they were trying to pull a fast one on
Loki so that General Docs could blow up
all the different branch timelines.
So he was kind of going according to plan,
even though it did seem like he went
rogue and went into the sacred timeline
in the past to create a life for himself.
part of the idea is that
he was trying to hide out in the sacred
timeline was the time
they were trying to preserve that
general doctor was blowing the branches,
not the sacred timeline.
lot of theories about what's
really going on with this character.
I think he's not exactly who he says
he is.
And obviously,
there's still the mystery of General Dox.
They just arrested her
at the end of the episode.
Hopefully we'll get an interrogation in.
We'll find out what's really going
on. Maybe they'll confirm some of that.
There is there are a couple of really
big theories about her character.
I felt like there were a couple of moments
in this episode
to support some of the crazier theories,
But we'll get to that in a second.
They start the episode, the opening scene
in 1977 London with Loki and Mobius
going to the zany movie
premiere in formal attire For all you
that wanted to see Loki wear a tuxedo
there's a bunch of Easter eggs
for real life movies and in universe
fake Marvel movies that he did
in a lot of different Marvel movies
where you have like fake movies,
like the movies that Kingo makes
They exit the portal right
next to a poster for The Lovebug,
which was a real movie
that Disney released back in the day.
and it's also a bit of a reference
to all the Disney of it all
because Disney owns
so the a lot of Disney references
that creep into Marvel
movies and Marvel TV shows.
the really
obvious Easter egg here for 1977.
Like why this year is
because we're talking about Disney.
Disney Al owns Star Wars.
The original Star Wars.
A new Hope movie premiered in 1977.
I literally just got done
doing videos for Star Wars.
Ahsoka Season one.
And there are many, many star Wars
references all across the Marvel movies.
in fact, Star Wars is canon to marvel.
that's
why Spider-Man is always referencing it.
the other big thing here too,
you notice when they show the time code,
they list them arriving.
It specifies the sacred timeline
as opposed to Sylvie's branch timeline
they just want to denote exactly
which universe they're in
because they're going to be visiting
multiple universes during the season,
even though they blow up a lot of them.
During this episode.
They come to the 1970s to catch Hunter X5
because they think that he knows
where Sylvie is.
they also want to capture him
and bring him back
because it looks like he's
also creating a Nexus event,
even though he claims he's not.
During the episode.
really important details here, too,
when Loki says he doesn't think
that Sylvie is in this place
because it's not a war
zone, it's not an apocalypse event.
That was her M.O.
Up to the events of season
one in Mobius correctly assumes
maybe she's changed her tactics.
I also think that's a bigger teaser
about what's going on with General Dox to
basically Mobius is right on the money
like Sylvie completely
try to leave it behind and hide out in
this brains timeline in Broxton, Oklahoma,
working at the McDonald's
because he didn't have anything
to do with any of them, including the TVA.
when they're walking through the alleyway,
they walk past a bunch of movie poster
Easter eggs.
The next one is for King Goes
First movie Son of Suresh.
This is the very first movie
that he ever made
when he actually started making movies.
They referenced
it during the Eternals movie,
his whole thing.
Is that because he was immortal,
he would just eventually pretend
to be his son,
then eventually grandson,
and so on and so forth.
they made a big joke about that.
How his friend, when he was a young child
and started
working for him, eventually saw that
he just never wound up dying.
He never age so eventually thought
he was a vampire and tried to stake him.
they referenced. KING Those movies
and a lot of other Marvel movies, too.
Like there were a couple of Kingo posters
for new movies that he made
during the Guardians of the Galaxy Holiday
special.
but currently he and most of the other
Eternals were taken by Ursula, the judge
back to the World Forge
where the celestial host will judge
if the earth remains
worthy to continue existing.
And if it's not, the basically come and
just completely wipe it out of the cosmos,
maybe they'll pay that off
in Eternals, too.
That winds up getting made.
Who knows?
It sounds like
they're developing in the background,
but that doesn't really mean anything.
They develop a lot of movies at Marvel
that never wind up getting made.
The next one they walk by
is four phone Ranger,
who is actually a marvel
character named Aggie Bell.
For Alexander Graham Bell,
who invented the telephone.
he has the ability to travel
along electrical lines
like phone based powers, basically,
if you look lower on the poster though,
there's an East for Goodman Productions.
Martin Goodman.
Originally on Timely Comics,
which is what Marvel Comics used
to be called
before they changed their name.
A couple of times. first
they were timely comics.
He hired a young Stan
Lee Stanley Lieber to work for them.
then they changed their name
to Atlas Comics.
Then they eventually changed their name
to Marvel Comics.
there are a couple of Easter eggs
like this during the Moon Knight series
for the origin of Marvel Comics.
timely Atlas production.
Because Timely Comics turned into Atlas
Comics, turned into Marvel Comics.
the actual movie premiere they're at
is the Zodiac movie.
That's a big, deep
cut for the Thor comics.
He was an evil entity who possessed
people, make them do evil things.
He debuted in the classic Thor Comics,
which is why they're using him in the Loki
series.
he started out possessing
someone in Victorian London like,
we're in the UK here.
That's why
they're using the Zenia character,
because he was largely a UK based villain
then in the present day at the time
when he came back in the door
comics, he possessed an actor
who was playing zany act in a movie,
but it was meant to be like a fake
in universe movie, so the real zany entity
possessed the actor playing the character,
turning him into the real zany act.
during the episode.
It just meant to be a funny Easter egg.
They don't actually turn the Hunter X5
character or Brad Wolf into actual ENIAC,
But basically they explained
that he's turned himself into Brad Wolf,
quote unquote.
It's not clear
if this was his original life
on the sacred timeline
before he became a variant
or if he just created this persona
out of whole cloth.
but I do think that his name
is actually an Easter egg that he chose.
The Brad Wolf name is an Easter egg.
I'll talk about in a second
when they walk into the lobby,
they play a seventies version of the Loki
theme music because this is the 1970s.
They explain
he basically went back in time
with his future technology
to become super famous,
and he's just trying to enjoy himself
while he can.
Basically learning that he was a variant
in episode one completely threw him off
the deep end like, No,
I don't want to do this anymore.
I want to go have fun.
They're couple references about him
dating Brigitte Bardot,
who was another huge movie
star at that time.
And he actually made this zany act movie.
So he'd been living in this
strange timeline for a number of years.
Mobius makes a reference to Zany Act
to a sequel movie.
The character did show up in later
Thor comics, but he only appeared
in a few times in all Thor comics.
So it's kind of like a joke, throwaway
character.
you can also call that a joke
about them doing Loki Season
two like it is a sequel to season one.
Are we going to see a sequel?
Hunter B-15 is with them to help
capture his tempered in the alleyway.
She's also decked out in seventies attire.
is almost like a holodeck mission
and like a Star Trek episode where they
dress up period appropriate to whatever
the scenario is that they're entering.
this is also to set up them going
back to the 1800s for the Victor time
episode, which
I think is going to be episode three.
we get to see Loki using his magic again
with a particular swagger
that we haven't seen from him in a while,
mostly because everything went so crazy
in episode one the Miller and King truck
that almost backs into them is a reference
to Sylvie in Thor.
Miller was actually the name of the man
who owned the land in Broxton,
Oklahoma,
where Thor put new Asgard in the comics.
Broxton is the place
where Sylvie is hiding out right now
at the McDonald's,
foreshadowing Loki, finding her later.
there's always tons of Thor
Easter eggs in all the Loki episodes
just because he is a Thor base character.
A lot of those that they trade in
or Thor references a lot of the stuff
that they're pulling from Arthur
comic books.
maybe we'll see a crossover
with Thor again at some point
or some more references
to the actual Thor character.
The producers did say, though,
their plan was to eventually
build up to a reunion
between this Loki in Thor.
At some point.
my assumption right now, unless there's
like some big Loki crossovers
with some other upcoming movies,
I don't think we're actually going
to see them reunite
with each other until either Avengers
five, Qing Dynasty or Secret Wars.
But it is kind of funny
that Loki season one was such a banger
like Loki worked so well
without the Thor character.
But. Thor, Love and Thunder
did not work without Loki.
how the tables have turned.
Now Loki is the much
more popular character
the funny thing about their little foot
chase here too is that Loki is a frost
giant, has naturally enhanced
strength, stamina, speed.
so we've been without his magic.
This is easy for him.
This is more of like a light jog, whereas
we don't really know
what's going on with the Hunter
X5 character.
Like, is he just a normal human
or does he have some special DNA in him?
He lives out his modified teleportation
device like the one that Loki stole
in the very first episode of the series.
Then they have a joke about a bunch
of punk rockers coming up on him.
But it winds up being an illusion
that Loki creates.
The other reference
here in the background to
is the idea of punk rock in Great Britain.
So the whole idea is the punk
rock movement started in the mid seventies
in the London area,
this is happening during 1977.
So this would be towards
the peak of the punk era.
but all these people
are just created by Loki.
So Loki is being very period specific,
creating these punk rockers,
basically winds up
pulling the same trick on Hunter X
five that he did during the first Avengers
movie, duplicating himself
and then capturing them with shadow
magic versions of himself, complete
with full Loki horns.
I don't know that we've seen him
use the shadow trick before.
That seems like a new wrinkle.
there was a funny moment during season
one where he went on about magic
like this, telling Mobius the difference
between illusions and duplication.
Magic like, No, no, no.
These are completely different abilities.
but. It is
a reminder that he is very good at magic.
He even tricks Mobius into thinking
one of the copies is the real version.
That's also one of the things about he
and Sylvie.
Sylvie is also very good at magic,
but she has different abilities.
She has more enchantment based abilities,
which we see later in the episode
because she's based a lot
on a more of the Enchantress combined
with Lady Loki from the comics.
I didn't see any changes during the custom
Loki title scene.
All the changing characters
are always just meant to be a reference
to all the different Loki variants,
back of the TVA, he makes a bunch of jokes
about being in cuffs in color himself
just last season, like kind of tight
how the tables have turned.
are a lot of moments in this episode
where they reference Loki's growth
as a character,
like he used to be very, very different.
they clocked that hunter.
X5 loves the talk
and I'm starting to build a theory
about who he really is, But
I'm waiting for a little more evidence.
I think he'll have a special connection
with the Loki character or a borrows,
basically tells them to examine
the modified tempered themselves,
making another joke
about never reading the manual.
That's mostly just a joke about everybody
in real life, not reading manuals,
basically the TVA manual is meant
to give them all the answers
about how everything, every minor
little piece, every major device,
everything works in the TVA
so they can solve all their problems
by just reading the manual.
my early theory
is that they'll be like some big problem
in the finale that they had to solve in.
They could have solved it in episode one
had they just read
the manual, or a Burroughs
is still trying to fix the temporal loom.
That sense of a bigger plot
that I think that they'll pay off
with the victor timely character.
I'll explain that in a second.
like no matter what they do, no matter
how they try, they can't fix the timeline
without the help of another king
who is Victor timely
every time there's a scene in his office
here like it looks amazing.
I love the way they do the set dressing.
But if you look in the background,
they're just thousands
and thousands of things
just sitting around all kinds of clutter.
Let me know if you think you spot
any Easter eggs or references in all this.
like if you look in the background,
zooming, enhance, there's a big taco sign.
Apparently there was a taco stand
at some point in the TVA
and now it's here in his shop
there's even an old banana in one of these
message tubes that somebody sent to him,
they use Hunter B-15 and Casey
to set up the Ren Slayers
storyline, explaining a little bit
about what's going on with her.
They find out that she's connected to
he remains because Loki explains the tape
about her helping him
create the TVA in the first place.
we learned they were
in a relationship like the comics,
like they were lovers in the comics.
She helped him win
the Kang Multiverse War.
She's kind of like the mother of the TVA,
but at some point he wiped her
memory, created the timekeepers,
and then retreated to his sizzle.
At the end of time,
during the end of season one,
when she was escaping,
she said she was off
to look for free will.
This season might be her slowly
getting her memories back.
they clock
that Miss Minutes is still inactive
and she's been purposefully
hiding herself.
Casey notes that he found her
last message on Ransley was ten bad.
So basically Ms..
Minutes has been helping Ren Slayer
and that's why
she has not been active at the TVA.
She's basically
been hiding herself from the tbey probably
because she was ultimately loyal to
he who remains in Ren Slayer was with Kang
like they were together creating the TVA
when he created Ms. Minutes
so if he remains.
Was Ms..
Min, his father, so to speak, then?
Renzulli
It would be kind of like her mother
that's probably
why she's been so protective of her
but I think part of the idea
with this episode
is that because all the different branch
timelines
almost get blown up, they're still three.
They're left at the end of the episode.
I think Ms.
Minutes is helping her jump
to different branch timelines to survive
and will lead her to victory time.
Lee Kang that's how Rensselaer winds up
intersecting with Loki and Mobius again
there are bunch of jokes about Mobius
and Loki not being able to figure out
how the temple works.
The Section 42 reference in his book
I think is meant to be an Easter egg
for The Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy
because 42 The Hitchhiker's Guide
is meant to be a book
that explains all of reality,
and that's basically
what the TVA manual is.
It explains everything in the TVA
and they basically give
this storyline to KC like KC
is a fanboy of the TVA manual.
He's read it cover to cover.
So he's a fanboy of or borrows
They don't really actually figure out
what that modified temple does
until they find General Doc's men inside
that warehouse, setting off all the bombs
in the different branch timelines.
But basically they're using them
to send all the different bombs,
the brains
timelines from a single location
so they don't have to manually
just go to every single other universe.
the couple
funny interrogation scenes
with Loki and Mobius Mobius basically
letting Loki try his hand
at interrogating someone.
Look how proud he looks like.
Look how far he's come.
Hunter X5 tries to get a reaction out
of Loki by throwing his past in his face.
Like, Aren't you supposed to be a villain?
Look at all
the terrible stuff you've done.
There's no way you could possibly turn
into a good person.
You're meant to be bad.
This is also really important
to pretty relevant.
At the beginning of their conversation,
he says everything that Loki
and Sylvie have done to try
and help has only made things worse.
I think this actually supports the theory
that General Docs
might be an older version of Sylvie,
who's completely changed her
tactics, like Mobius suggested
at the beginning of the episode.
like this older version of Sylvie
is remorseful about what they've done,
trying to fix everything and tries
a completely different tactic
she got arrested
at the end of the episode,
so I'm really hoping by episode three
or episode four, somebody interrogates
the truth out of her and we find out
what's really going on with the character.
I think that's one of the reasons
why General Docs is so adamant
that she captures Sylvie
because it's younger Sylvie,
so she's trying to capture her
younger self
before she does some of the stuff
that they do during this season.
he makes a bunch of references
to the other Loki variants
they've arrested over the years
of the TVA. There have been many.
and we met a large chunk of them
during season one.
really hoping that we get to see alligator
Loki again at some point.
the only time he's ever able
to get an actual reaction out of Loki
is when he brings up his mother Frigga
throwing her death in his face.
But if you remember this, Loki
hasn't experienced that yet
because he was arrested
and taken to the TVA
after the events of the first Avengers
movie before Frigga would die.
but he did have to watch her death,
so he learned that
that would be his destiny eventually.
So he had to kind of live
with that memory.
So he feels like he also kills her, even
though he didn't actually do it himself.
but he's kind of pulling the same trick
on Loki that Loki pulled on The Avengers
during the first Avengers movie.
There are a lot of references to that
first Avengers movie in this episode.
Loki basically baiting The Avengers
into attacking him,
using the chaos as a way to escape
when he calls Loki a loser.
That's the real you.
That's a reference to Mobius.
His conversation
during their interrogation during season
one episode one saying
that Loki was always destined to lose.
It was in his nature,
which is a callback to Coulson's death
during the first Avengers movie.
one of my early theories here
too, is his name that he takes for himself
when he's hiding out on the sacred
timeline is Brad Wolf.
Wolf, as an animal, I think
he might wind up being Loki's future son.
in his name,
Wolf, is a reference to Fan Wolf,
who is Loki's son in Norse mythology.
In the MCU, though,
the actual like big fan was Wolf.
Actual wolf was Heller's wolf.
the other weird thing
about this interrogation room is it
is almost built like a giant containment
facility, like a giant tank.
All the walls, the ceiling,
the floor are metal.
There's a drain that that chair sits on.
Like they interrogate people
and fill the room
with a bunch of fluid or something
like that,
generally implying
that a lot of really terrible stuff
happens in this room
When Mobius takes over the interrogation,
they make a bunch of jokes about this
not being real.
Mobius jokes about not being an actor
when Owen Wilson is, in fact an actor.
They're all actors, and none of what
we're seeing is actually real.
So they're kind of clowning on the Loki
series just in general.
he starts
making fun of Mobius for his past.
Like you don't even know
what your actual name is.
Mobius isn't your real name.
Who were you on the sacred timeline
before you became a variant?
I think we're all assuming
that it was something to do with jetskis,
lashes out at them.
And I think this is meant to be part of
Mobius Arc this season.
Like he'll learn more about
his actual past and make peace with that.
probably still going to love jetskis
no matter what though
They wander into the automat, making
a couple of jokes about getting lost
in the TVA because it's so massive
and it's built kind of like a 3-D. M.C.
Escher painting.
basically
this is meant to be one of the cafeterias.
But the funny thing is it only sells pie
like it's pie all over the place.
So it's just kind of like the pie
cafeteria.
they both have a piece,
both really enjoying it.
And it's meant to pay off
that moment from season one
where Loki said
they never really eaten candy
before in his life.
They never were eaten sweets
Mobius asked him
if he had candy and Asgard,
and he's like, yeah, sure.
We have grape nuts.
And use that as an example
for why Loki had caused so many problems
have been so disgruntled his entire life.
Like just had some candy to chill out.
but this scene is meant to be more about
Loki being the one to actually talk
some sense into Mobius
showing how much he has grown
is a person basically recounting
the events of the first Avengers movie.
Like the reason he made the bargain
with Thanos for the Infinity Stones,
trying to take over
the Earth was only because he was mad
at Thor and Odin they've covered this
in the previous Marvel movies.
I guess we've seen Loki's
character develop,
basically he just wanted to feel like
he was part of the family,
like he felt like Odin never loved him in
Thor, never cared about him.
So that's why
he was so pissed off at them.
he wanted to conquer Earth
so that Odin would acknowledge him.
He tells them the story about Iron Man
with the Mind
stone in the Avengers Tower,
like trying to use it on him,
then throwing it out the
window because he lost it,
Basically his
example of losing his cool
during an interrogation like Mobius,
although I wouldn't call that
an interrogation.
Loki was really trying to get Iron Man
to submit to him in that moment, like,
just quit now, The Mobius claims
that he's never actually visited
his original life on the sacred timeline,
like he's never actually tried to peep
what his life used to be
because he's been so focused on
moving forward, like he doesn't
want to be obsessed with his past.
I think part of the idea is that
he hasn't made peace with that,
and he'll do that at some point
this season.
here's
where we get to a really big Easter egg.
I think that they'll eventually
pay off later this season.
He references the guy who kidnaped him in
the first place and brought into the TVA
and got him
this pie. Here's the big twist.
I think they might actually say that
it was Loki or a future version of Loki,
who captures Mobius in the past
and first brought him to the TVA.
Remember, we have crazy time travel logic
here with the TVA like future
version of Loki at some point
eventually goes back further in the past
and and grabs the original variant
of Mobius and becomes part of the TVA.
so this Loki hasn't experienced it yet
and doesn't realize that it's actually him
that Moby's is talking about.
Meaning like,
I want to shake the hand of the guy
that originally stole me
from the sacred timeline.
well, you're staring at him right here.
end, I think this gets back
to the whole concept of Aura borrows
like the title of episode
one in time loops time repeating.
And that might also explain why.
Could be Loki, who originally
pruned himself in episode one.
But even though the moment
that we're seeing is from the finale
like that happened in episode one,
but Loki jumps forward to the future,
so he sees the older version of Sylvie,
who's come back to the TVA
in The person who proved him
might be an older version of Loki.
is a very doctor who kind of thing
they're pulling this season with the time
looping back on itself.
I think we'll continue to see references
to that, like moments where characters
reference things that they themselves
wind up doing in the future.
one of the other big tropes of Doctor
Who stories is that
even though it is a big time travel series
and you're supposed to have time
travel rules that you can't break, Doctor
who breaks its own internal logic rules
all the time back inside the temporal loom
control room.
OB starts working on it.
It locks him out
because he has an invalid temporal
or basically he doesn't have the right
temporal signature, like the right person
to operate the machinery.
It has to be
the person who originally created it.
this will probably wind up being Victor
timely
because the person
who originally created this,
he who remains, which they reference
later in the episode, is dead.
But if they get Victor Townley King, he's
another king who has the exact same DNA.
It's the exact same person
just from another universe
They're a couple of trailer scenes
that imply he's back in the TVA,
helping them with this problem.
But who better to fix time itself
than another king
And just an idea that Victor timely king
will be a helpful variant of king.
Not all the variants of King will be evil.
they go back to mess with Hunter five,
a little more with his torture device.
Boxing him in
the quantum portal is designed
to act more like containment
devices, shrinking
until it can either hurt them they crack
or it crushes them like a can of pop.
Then he reveals what's really going on
with Sylvie hiding out
at the McDonald's in Brockton
and why he bailed on the mission.
Basically, the idea is that
he knew what was going to happen.
General Doc's
plan to blow up
all the alternate timelines
so he wanted to go hide out
on the main timeline
because he felt like General
Doc's was going to be successful end,
there was no threat to him being blown up
because he was on the sacred timeline.
that was the timeline
the General Doc's was trying to preserve
They also make
it sound like it was a complete ruse too.
Like General Doc's plan for Hunter
x5 to be captured in told him to basically
just take them to Sylvie
and use that as a way to distract them
while she blew up all the other timelines.
the couple funny moments
when they introduce Obie to Cassie.
Like I said, Total Fangirl, Will you
please sign my book next to your picture?
My guess is they don't remember meeting
because they've been at the TVA
this whole time
because they got their minds
wiped on a periodic basis.
Although apparently or Burrows
remembers things to about 400 years ago,
But I think a lot of
this is just to make Casey a much bigger
character during season two, like
give him a reason because he knows
everything inside the TVA manual.
So it'll be really helpful to them
in future episodes.
Loki and Mobius travel in Sylvie's
McDonald's with Hunter X5.
We saw this in the trailers.
They did a couple of funny promos
for McDonald's.
It was kind of hard to tell
what was going to be in the actual episode
they mostly played the reunion for comedy
because Loki comes in assuming
things are going to be super intense,
but really just super awkward.
And Sylvie really is
just trying to chill out here.
Like she just wanted
anything to do with them or the TVA
when they actually meet in the same frame,
they play some of Loki's sad theme music.
I think that's from The Lament.
This episode,
He explains his time slipping
and what's going wrong this season.
Sylvie is still trying
to refuse coming back until eventually
they learn
what's really going on with the bombs.
basically he has to remind her
about the Council of Kings.
Like even if you're
trying to hide out here, eventually
the Council of Kings will come to try
and destroy the sacred timeline.
So it won't matter where you hide
The couple of funny moments with Mobius
is chowing down on that McDonald's.
I kind of want
a little bit of McDonald's now.
Mission accomplished.
That was probably their evil plan
all along.
Just get people more hyped up to eat more.
McDonald's
just have Moebius chowing down on it.
They make more Hollywood more zany act
movie references like No, no, no.
It was a work of art.
Basically trying to tell him
this. ENIAC was cinema.
You could call that just a reference
to everybody who loves Marvel movies,
everybody who hates Marvel movies. Like,
No, no, no.
They're cinema. Other people say,
They're just regular comic book movies
and nothing special.
but the real reason why he's so adamant
that he wants to get back the TVA,
like he keeps yelling at them.
Please take me back to the TVA.
We'll continue this conversation.
You can put this in it.
To go back is because he knows
about all the bombs going off.
He doesn't want to be caught
by General Doc's men.
Sylvie finally uses
her enchanting powers again to learn
General Doc's plans about all the bombs.
They go to the warehouse
and try to stop them.
They're only able to save a couple branch
timelines.
But for the most part,
General Doc's is successful in wiping out
most of the others
there's all the theories
about General Doc's
being the older version of Sylvie.
But here's the thing about General Doc's
plan with the bombs
and the other timelines
issues, basically using a reverse version
of Sylvie's plan in season one,
which is that all the bombs are creating
all the other branch timelines.
General Docs, which is pushing them
into other reality, setting them off
at the same time so that it would destroy
the branch timelines
We get a real quick
team up moment with Loki and Sylvie
using their powers together again,
combining their powers,
going for Captain Planet
like they did during season one.
the whole idea
when they combine their powers,
there's like a stacking bonus
that they get,
they become way more powerful
and each one of them
could be by themselves.
they arrest general dogs.
Like I said, hopefully
we'll get an interrogation with her.
We'll get some more answers about
what's really going on with the character.
Sylvie comes back to see what's happened,
in they managed to save three branch
timelines just enough to find a branch
with Victor timely variant of King
in next week's episode.
notice on the TVA's panel here too.
It says Branch 616
with a bunch of other characters.
That's because 616 is the sacred timeline.
They're saying that 616 is the main
Marvel universe,
which they've done
in a couple of other Marvel movies
like Doctor Strange,
Multiverse of Madness,
they'll be arguments in the fandom
about this for years.
Like if you are a big fan of Agents of
SHIELD, they used to call Earth 1999999.
They also did that during Spider-Man
across the Spider-Verse.
So a lot of people are like,
Wait a minute, which is correct.
Is MCU Earth 19999, or is the Earth 616?
Like Kevin Feige is saying, Generally,
the most correct answer
is like the last person left standing
or the highest person on the totem pole.
So I would just go with whatever
Kevin Foggy is saying in each movies.
Like for the purposes of the Loki series
in the Marvel movies or the MCU,
Marvel movies the main MCU is 616,
but they call it something different
when you're in other people's universes,
we'll get to like the next ten Avengers
movies
and people will still be arguing about it.
So don't think too about it.
the reason why they probably got a hit
on Rent Slayers ten pad is because Ms..
Menace has been helping save her,
probably helped
save her from the bombings,
causing her to use it
a bunch of times in succession
and that's what pinged it on their system.
like rent.
Slayer jumped here just before the bombs
went off in the branch timeline
that she had been in.
zooming in hands on this
read out here to notice she's listed
as TVA entity 221a
in her variant number is 223.
she's probably from the original universe
designation 2 to 1 in the A designation
might mean she's
the original variant of the character
which it makes sense
if she was working with.
He remains during the K multiverse war
and helped create the TVA.
She would be like
one of the original variants at the TVA.
the 2 to 3 number might be a reference
to her first appearance in the comics,
which was Avengers
23 way back in the 1960s.
Then you notice that Sylvie still has
he remains special, advanced tempered
from the end of season one.
That's why she swipes her wrist.
It's a wrist activated device.
her universe.
In Brock's in Oklahoma,
there is one of the three branches
that survived when they're talking,
there's like, this weird guy
in a white jumpsuit
just sitting behind them doing nothing.
You just seem kind of odd to me.
He's just like one of the extra people
at the TVA just watching everything go on.
but the way he's sitting there in frame
the way the camera kind of focused on him
seemed kind of odd to me.
what is he doing? What is he cooking?
back of the McDonald's. Sylvie
seems like she's torn about what to do.
She doesn't know if she really does
want to come back.
She looks at he remains tempered.
I believe the spaghetti problem
from episode one that Örebro has talked
about
is what causes her to actually come back.
Probably in episode three.
I think the idea is like
you see these in the trailers.
If things start to break down or a borrows
that might wind up happening
if they don't fix the temporal loop in
until they get Victor timely King's help
things are still breaking down around them
like reality is collapsing around them.
And I think Sylvie starts
to see that happen in her reality.
And Braxton is like, crap,
now I do have to go back.
They play a brand new song over the end
credits.
In most of the end credits
seems like all these different Easter
eggs,
the different scenes that they mash up in
show are mostly the same,
except for the files.
At the end,
They added the Hunter x five file
to the pile, the Loki mobius in tuxedos.
Sylvie in the McDonald's outfit
General Docks KC 150.
Basically all moments
the pictures were taken from episode two.
I think the idea is this is meant to be
a scene of Moby is just investigating
what happened during the episode
and they did kind of something
similar during season one were.
They made it seem like someone was
investigating all the characters episode
to episode with minor changes to the files
that were being examined.
but. Overall, it was a solid episode.
I didn't think it was quite
as good as episode one.
But I think once Victor Timely joins
the series like once Ren Slayer
comes back,
things really start to get crazy.
Like episode three will be the halfway
point of the season.
I think that's when they really start
ramping things up.
there are a bunch of Easter eggs
and references in the episode.
So if you think you spotted any
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments
and let me know
who do you think that General Dox
really is?
my Episode 3 Trailer video
We'll post this weekend in my full episode 3
video we'll post next week
after they release it.
There's a couple of big things
happening this weekend, too,
because New York Comic-Con is happening.
So to be a couple of big trailers.
and my
Boys Gen V Episode 5 Video
should post Friday night
click here for that Episode
3 Trailer video Update the link
as soon as I post that and click here
for all my other Loki videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!